ochio and other Japanese cities Craig
Nelson's new book the first heroes
examines the military and psychological
impact of the raid just four months
after Pearl Harbor he spoke recently at
the Smithsonian Discovery Theatre in
Washington DC for about an hour I cannot
tell you what a thrill it is to be
invited from the hinterlands to speak at
the Smithsonian for those of you who
live in the Washington area and wander
in and out of these museums at your
Caprice you probably don't realize that
the rest of us think of this is the
American crown jewels so to be invited
here you know I thought oh I'll be so
happy if three people come so for all of
you to come I'm just shocked right out
of my pants I can't even tell you how
exciting it is I do have to warn some of
you however the whole reason I really
wrote this book and the whole reason in
the whole way I've organized this
program is for people who've never heard
of the Doolittle Raid and I can tell by
looking into some of your eyes that some
of you have heard of the Doolittle Raid
but I promise if you'll be a little bit
patient you'll hear some things you
might not know because the whole reason
I did this book when I started on it my
friend said why are you doing this but I
think once you hear about the incredible
human drama
of this story you'll see why anyone who
wants to write a nonfiction book would
want to tell this story now the first
thing I have to tell you especially
those under the age of 55 who may not be
up on this history is that this is a
story that begins at one of the darkest
phases of American history now it may be
that there was a darker moment during
the Revolutionary War when it was iffy
whether or not the nation was going to
be born and it may be that there was a
darker moment during the Civil War when
it looked as though the nation might
dissolve entirely but Pearl Harbor and
the resulting Nazi submarine attacks
along the East Coast were way up there
as far as black moments go and you know
recently we've heard an awful lot about
oh nine eleven is so much like Pearl
Harbor well it just isn't you know we
have spent 50
years being the premier global
superpower at the time of Pearl Harbor
we weren't even in the top ten we were
number 14 we were behind Sweden and
Portugal and just to get a feel of what
this was like
while the Germans just the Germans had
seven million men in their army and navy
America had 500,000 and also at this
time not only were we beaten down by the
Great Depression and really not much of
a military power the whole concept of
made in the USA didn't mean much a
perfect example of that is the Japanese
had a torpedo that went 24 miles and was
tremendously accurate while the best
American torpedo went 50 400 yards and
always missed in fact for any of you who
have ever read the naval history of
World War two you're going to spend all
of 42 and 43 saying to yourself damn
those torpedoes because they're always
missing when Americans are having an
engagement so what happened at Pearl
Harbor and during that Nazi submarine
attack by the way those of you who
aren't familiar immediately after Pearl
Harbor and the Nazis and a squadron of
submarines to take down freighters
primarily those traveling between Texas
and the Northeast carrying fuel and they
were so successful at this that the
British began sending accompanying
destroyers to protect their ships and
American coastal waters Torres in Miami
could run down to the beach and see a
freighter set ablaze at night and the
shadow of a Nazi u-boat image in it's
fire so what happened in America after
Pearl Harbor was a mass and to panic in
Washington DC Marines set up machine
guns on the corners and we shipped the
Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence off to Fort Knox but the
hardest hit were the people along the
west coast farmers were patrolling the
beaches of pupae death sound with their
pitchforks looking for incoming Japanese
aircraft carriers
the civil defense chief of San Francisco
announced on a regular basis that they
were about to be invaded at any minute
while the Los Angeles Times even printed
a headline saying that all of Southern
California had been invaded by the
Japanese and this is where our story
starts with a group of 80 men who are
operating out of Pendleton Oregon and
they are flying a plane known as the b25
and they're looking for incoming
Japanese submarines and this may sound
like an exciting job but in fact it's
tremendously dull you fly out in your
plane and you make a square and you look
at every inch in that square and you
don't find anything and you do that
every day twice a day that you have
permissible weather and it's quite dull
and the planes these men are flying are
not that different in quality from those
American torpedoes the top turret is so
badly designed that when the gun machine
gun on the top rear of the plane is
fired at its full downward tilt it rips
off the fuselage from the skin of the
plane the bottom turret is so badly
designed that the gunners using its
periscope and its hand gun usually get
too sick to be able to aim they get so
disoriented but my favorite feature of
this airplane is that the men would find
on a regular basis that the shackles
wouldn't release the bombs out of the
bomb bay which is not a feature you want
to have in your bomber so there they are
they're out looking for Japanese
submarines it's tremendously boring and
six weeks after Pearl Harbor their
officers asked them to a meeting and at
the meeting they say we're looking for
volunteers it's for a secret mission
you'll be out of the country for about
four months it's going to be very
dangerous
besides that we can't tell you anything
now this may not sound like something
you'd jump to do but those men did they
had been in the Army Air Corps for about
a year they had been trained for combat
Pearl Harbor it happened and they wanted
in
so they took the best of them and they
ship them off to the secret training
ground that the Army Air Corps had in
the Florida Panhandle called Eglin and
the reason they had their secret
training ground at Eglin was because no
one with any sense went anywhere near
there it was a palmetto swamp filled
with mosquitoes and the first thing
these men were taught to do in England
was something called an abrupt takeoff
now when you take off from your big 747
down to go to the Caribbean you use a
runway of about 10,000 feet but these
guys in these little planes the planes
only hold five men in about five bombs
they took off in about 1,500 feet at
Eglin they had to do it in under five
hundred feet or they're off the mission
and the way this was done was put on the
brakes all the way you put down the
flaps all the way it turned up the gas
all the way and you let go of the brakes
and the plane would skedaddle like this
down the runway and then right at about
the 500 point it would jump into the air
like that and at first the guys doing
this thought this was nerve-racking but
then they started thinking it was lots
of fun and not only could a lot of them
get it off in 500 feet one of them did
it in 287 the next thing they were
taught was something called
hedge-hopping which literally means
hedge-hopping they flew these planes so
low that their altima ters read zero
they flew under bridges and powerlines
they like to tear a fight at Alinta
stampeding they had to rise up to go
over barns and houses and when I
interviewed the men about this the
pilots and co-pilots driving the planes
thought this hedge-hopping was just
terrific
the gunners bombin tears and navigators
sitting more or less in the backseat
helpless did not think it was quite that
terrific so after they were trained in
these two things the very best of the
men got to see their modified planes and
the planes had been modified in two
specific ways the bottom gun that made
everyone sick was removed it was
replaced by two broomsticks painted
black
the top secret weapon that all the Baba
deers use which was called the Norden
gun site it was a bomb site
there was an analog computer and you
would program it for speed and wind and
direction it would take over the
autopilot of the plane drop the bombs
and then turn the plane around and
return control of the plane back to the
pilot was also removed when the bomb
adheres as why they were missing their
top-secret computer their commander said
it's inevitable that some of your planes
will fall into enemy hands but the
strangest thing that it should change
Don these planes was that there were
these rubber gas tanks installed
everywhere in every possible piece of
space and they would have a lot of
trouble with these gas tanks because
just like the American torpedoes they
were not designed so well it turned out
that these bulletproof gas tanks which
have two skins of rubber on them were
Mis sized the outer skin was too small
for the inner skin so these gas tanks
would leak all the way across this
mission okay now that we're down to the
80 best possible men and those 80 men
are invited to meet their commander and
this is an exciting moment since until
then they don't know who their commander
is and they walk in and the guy at the
podium is someone straight out of their
childhood dreams it's almost impossible
to describe the impact seeing this man
had on them it would be as if you were
asked to join a secret tennis ski team
and it turns out your teammates are the
Williams sisters or or you're invited to
play golf and the guy you're playing
with is Tiger Woods I mean they are so
thrilled and it's this remarkably tiny
yet remarkably great man they look at
named Jimmy Doolittle now when you write
a nonfiction book or a biography or
something like that you're supposed to
keep a cool objective attitude about all
the characters you're writing about
you're not supposed to go nuts about any
of them well it's impossible to write
about Jimmy Doolittle without going nuts
about him in fact previous writers have
gone so nuts they sort of turned him
into this nutty cartoon character
Jimmy would eventually
have I think something like a hundred
thousand men serve over under him over
the course of World War two you could
not find anything but the highest of
praise from any of these men he was
famous at the time he was met by the
boys of this mission for being the most
astounding daredevil pilot to still be
alive at that moment he had flown planes
that had killed all the other pilots who
tried them he broken the
transcontinental speed record if you go
to the Air and Space Museum you can see
the seaplane he used to win an
international seaplane race this was the
only time he'd ever flown a seaplane
which really thrilled the Navy but the
thing he wanted to be famous for was
being the first man to fly only on
instruments and this would be the
equivalent of if you're driving down the
highway and you're driving at 70 miles
an hour and all your windows have been
painted black and you keep from driving
off the road by looking at one tile that
goes like this
and you keep from hitting other cars by
looking at another tile that goes like
this
and that's what Jimmy did he took off
circled the field and landed completely
blind using two extremely primitive
instruments and it's the whole reason we
today can fly at night and in fog and
this is what he wanted to be remembered
for but instead he's remembered for what
happens next he comes to the podium he
looks at the guys he says thank you so
much for coming you're the best we can
get for this mission if you hear of
anyone speaking anything about this
mission let me know I'll turn him over
to the FBI
good work thanks a lot a couple of days
later at 3 o'clock in the morning these
80 men are called and told to fly across
the country to Alameda California which
is right outside of San Francisco it was
where the Navy had their sort of mid
Pacific launch point on the west coast
and as they approached tell me that they
saw a little tiny teeny teeny speck down
at the ground and as they landed they
realized it was an aircraft carrier and
their planes and men were hustled aboard
this aircraft carrier
the aircraft carrier took off surrounded
by its armada of defensive ships and as
they passed under the Golden Gate Bridge
the captain announced this force is
bound for Tokyo now it is really
impossible to explain to people today
what bombing Tokyo met at this moment
Japan had won a series of battles taking
over all of Pacific Asia that had
startled everyone and had sort of
flummoxed
all of the countries that would become
known as the allies and they were
considered so mighty that the idea of
bombing them was considered a suicide
mission
and in fact the men told me that on the
one hand when this announcement came and
was some afford to all the other ships
of this Armada you could hear the
screams of people shouting for joy
coming from every ship as the message
was transferred along and half of the
men felt that way too they couldn't wait
for payback they couldn't wait to be the
men who did this no matter what happened
but the other half knew this was a
suicide mission and they weren't going
to come home alive and hearing what
twenty four year olds in 1942 thought
about this is something that really
stirred me I'll never forget what some
of them said one of them said there I
was on that boat and I couldn't get in
touch with my wife or my kids and all I
wondered was why hadn't I been a better
husband and father and another said you
know you're going to be scared I thought
I was going to be so scared but I wasn't
scared this incredible feeling of calm
came over me and all I wanted was to do
a good job so those feelings of the
secondary group would start taking over
from the excitement of the other group
as this Armada sped towards Japan it
turns out that this whole idea had been
Franklin Roosevelt's and he and in fact
been trying to bomb Japan for quite some
time he had set up the Flying Tigers of
American volunteer group to do it when
they failed he was in the middle of
second sending over a replacement group
of American volunteers or to Flying
Tigers when Pearl Harbor him
he insisted that his army and Navy
Chiefs figure out a way of doing this
and they replied that it was impossible
because at that time the Army Air course
did not have enough flying fields to
take off from that were close enough for
their distances to bomb Japan and the
Navy couldn't get close enough without a
fear of a retaliatory counter-strike
that would have destroyed all the ships
that hadn't been taken down at Pearl
Harbor and one day a guy by the name of
frog lo who would become head of the
submarines for all of American World War
two was sitting on an airstrip and he
was looking at the window and in the
airstrip the Navy had painted the
outline of an aircraft carrier so that
pilots could practice taking off and
landing without rolling off the end of
the deck and he saw the shadow of two
army bombers pass overhead and he
decided the only solution was an army
bomber on a navy aircraft carrier and
even though they hated each other's guts
the head of the Navy Ernie King and the
head of the Army Air Corps HAP Arnold
decided this had some merit to it and
they realized that there was only one
plane that could do this and it was
those terrible b-25s flown by these guys
in Oregon so I like to say that if you
are a World War two veteran or no one
any of those 7 million guys could have
been on this mission because the only
thing that qualified for the men of this
mission was the fact that they had been
flying the one Army Air Corps plane I
could fit on a navy aircraft carrier so
the missions plan is they're going to
get within 450 miles of Japan they're
going to launch in the morning they're
going to arrive over Japan in darkness
they're going to bomb Japan and then
they're going to land in Kuman tang
controlled Allied airfields in China
none of this is going to happen instead
they're spotted by Japanese spy boats
688 miles away not 450 miles away the
spy boat is sunk but the radio is able
to pick up that the spy boat has known
like Tokyo of the approaching Armada the
Navy has dedicated almost every ship
it's got two faring the two little
Raiders they can't keep going towards
Tokyo the 80 men are told it's your last
chance are we going or are we not going
even though we don't have enough gas to
make it the men say we're going the
extraordinary thing that happens first
is that the launches take a go off
without a single hitch one guy has his
flaps in the wrong position and he even
takes off just fine and because they're
having such gales in such wind that
they've got 30 knots giving them lift
and every single plane takes off without
any problem however the one exciting
thing I want to point out about doing
this which I didn't realize is that the
when you take off from an aircraft
carrier the guy at the bow telling you
when to lift off is calculating the ship
rising and falling like this so what
happens is that you spend an awful lot
of your time taxiing towards the bow
while you're pointed straight at the
ocean and then sort of at the last
minute the boat lifts legs up and your
take off so why don't we look at some of
that
okay so here you can see a wonderful
ship called the hairy carrier we're
going to meet her men in a little bit he
or she is tied down and chucked on the
deck of the Hornet and if you look at
this Plexiglas nose here's where the
Bombardier sits with his forward thirty
caliber browning and he's supposed to
move it in and out of these holes in the
nose you can see and that's sort of like
moving a Volkswagen engine around to
chase an enemy fighter so you can see
what a terrific design that one's these
are some men one of the crews they're
going to end up in the Soviet Union
all of these men except for the one on
the far left are going to end up dead
I'm sorry
and these men except for the two in the
middle Oh
the one on this side and the two on that
side will survive the two in the middle
will die the one hiding his nose will
become one of the most famous Raiders of
all time his name is Jake DeShazer we'll
be getting to him in a minute
and here are the boats on the Hornet you
can see some of their destroyers that
are protecting them this is a wood deck
and here comes takeoff these are stills
from a film and the film is shot by a
navy cameraman who would become the most
famous director of westerns in Hollywood
history his name is John Ford
this film is very misleading however
because the waves are actually 30 feet
high and they're crashing over the deck
of the ship it's raining non-stop people
are actually holding onto plates of the
deck to keep from being washed overboard
but none of that comes out in this movie
and I don't know why but here we go and
actually what you're missing is that
this great big fat bomber
is waddling like a duck as it makes it
into the takeoff here you can see the
rear dorsal gunner the one that takes
the skin off if you fire it too low and
here they come well okay so all the
planes very successfully take off but
they don't arrive over Tokyo at night
they arrive at high noon and they don't
arrive unseen they have to all pass over
Tokyo Harbor on their way in so they're
seen by every ship sitting there but in
an astounding quid-pro-quo
the commanders in Hawaii had ignored
every warning that Japan was approaching
Pearl Harbor now the Japanese would
ignore every warning that American boat
American planes were approaching them
and they were just not ready and
literally the Doolittle Raiders were
able to successfully target every single
one of their sites which were things
like ammo dumps and airplane factories
and machine gun yards and places like
that they was successfully bombed every
single target and the only thing that
happened was one of the planes got a
little bit of its skin ripped up and
that's it
then they reach China and started
running out of gas but before we get to
that let me tell you about Russia now in
the book I'm actually able to tell you
this whole story chronologically and hop
back and forth between all these
multiple stories and it's not confusing
at all and when I tried to do that for
you tonight I got so confused I couldn't
remember where we were so unfortunately
we have to hop around but anyway the
first plane to actually land has its
carburetors set so badly that it can't
even make it to China it decides to go
to Vladivostok if you look on a map
Vladivostok is actually right next to
Japan and at that time of course Russia
wasn't a lie but Russia was not at war
with Japan the men think will land there
they'll give us some gas we'll be on our
way that is what happens they land there
the Soviets enter in them as hostile
aliens to not enrage Japan and get
attacked in the East while they're
losing the western half of the country
to the Germans the guys first live quite
well with caviar and friends and the
radio and nice Russian cigarettes but
after a while they're freezing to death
and they're eating pork fat for lunch
and they decide the only answer is to
write a letter to Stalin and they do
this saying we want to be sent south
where we're not freezing and we want you
to give us something to do we're trained
engineers we can do lots of things with
planes do something with us two months
later two big muckety-mucks for Moscow
show up and go did you write this letter
to Stalin and they go yes we did and the
muckety-mucks say okay well we're going
to let you do this and they're sent down
to a southern part of the Soviet Union
now known as um OSH Chabad the capital
of Turkmenistan and they're set to work
repairing airplanes and while there they
meet an import-export guy who's got a
best friend who's a smuggler whose
secrets the mount in the back of a truck
to the safety of Iran so those guys get
out safely
the other men meanwhile I've decided
they need to abandon their planes and
bail out of all the training they've had
from the Army Air Corps the one thing
the Air Corps forgot was to train them
how to use parachutes now I don't know
how many of you have interviewed World
War two vets but there are notoriously
tight grip tight lipped Bunch and when I
asked these guys so was it scary taking
off from the Hornet oh no no not scary
was it scary bombing Japan oh no not
scary well how about when you're falling
out of the plane and you never used a
parachute and it's the middle of the
night in the middle of the rainstorm
it's on the other side of the world and
you're not sure if you're going to land
in the mountain top of a tree and a
village on the end of a Japanese bayonet
how about that oh yeah they said that
was pretty scary and I do have to say I
don't think ever again will I ever have
be able to write a book where you get to
end a chapter with characters falling
out of a plane and hanging from cliffs
literal cliff hangers are in this book
and the things the guys have to say
about doing this are I think some of the
best parts of the book one of them
because of the way the wind and the rain
is blowing jumps and pulls his parachute
but he becomes confused and he becomes
convinced that he's dead
so as he's falling he's looking around
and he doesn't understand what happened
to st. Peter so he lands but he still
thinks he's dead and he goes off looking
for st. Peter and when he can't find him
he decides he must be alive another man
is terrified that there's not going to
be anything to eat in China and he jumps
out holding a whole bunch of cans of
provisions and as he's falling he
realizes he doesn't have a free hand to
pull the ripcord and he thinks about
this for a while and he decides that if
he lets go of all the cans they'll fall
right alongside him he can pull the
ripcord and reach out and grab them all
back again this isn't what happens he
pulls the ripcord the cans get thrown
into the air by the wind he gets thrown
into the air by the RIP of the cord the
cans rain down on his
head and he touches down and things well
at least I'll be able to get these cans
but he never finds a single one of them
now there are a lot of sad parts to this
story but there are a lot of remarkably
happy parts too and one of them happens
right now what happens next is that
almost all of these men land safely
three of eighty died in the bailout and
almost all of them are carried across
six hundred miles of rural China by
peasants who can't understand a single
thing they're saying or writing under
the nose of the Japanese to the safety
of Chongqing and in fact the men of the
story wanted me to write this book so
that people would know what the Chinese
had done for them and there are so many
incredible stories about this I can't
possibly begin to tell you but I have to
tell you one of my favorites all right a
whole plane load of crew which is five
guys has been reunited and they're
traveling and traveling and traveling
and traveling and to avoid the gaze of
the Japanese they're taking all these
back roads and finally they come to a
town after weeks of doing this and then
look at that town and they think real
food hot water baths they're dirty
they're starving they haven't even had
enough water to trick really and the
Chinese say no you have to wait and
hours go by and they're still waiting
and the men start to get a little
frightened because they don't really
know what's going on and they think
maybe they're negotiating with the
Japanese to turn us over and as they
wait more and more hours this sort of
paranoia starts festering and they think
should we steal their gun should we
knock them on the head should we run
away but if we run away where would we
go they don't even know what they are
and just as they're about to do
something they hear off in the distance
the reason they've been waiting was so
that the town's marching band could
learn how to play the star-spangled
banner' so that the marching band could
accompany them through a parade of the
town where the populace had written
banners in English to hang from the
street poles welcome brave American
fliers and the guys who told me this
story said they cried every step of this
parade another somewhat happy story
happens with one man who has to have his
leg cut off in China he tries to land
instead of bailing out and is hideously
injured among much of his crew and he
comes back to America about eight months
later and at this time losing a leg was
sort of like being a circus freak it was
very bizarre and people were actually
very thoughtful about it and he's
terrified his wife is going to leave him
so he decides he's going to wait till he
gets his heart official leg and waits
till he gets all fixed up with all of
his surgery and then he's going to let
her know he's back in town and Jimmy
Doolittle says no you aren't he calls
the wife the wife comes to Walter Reed
and she sees him and in order to
recreate that story this man would end
up writing a best-selling book so I was
able to get rights from the book and
excerpt would he epistate died about 20
years ago and I was able to interview
his widow last year and I was able to
alternate the two of them telling this
story and so in his book he says that he
sees his wife in the doorway and he gets
so excited he forgets he's missing a leg
and he stands up and falls on his face
and I asked his widow about this moment
this is one of the toughest cookies you
could ever possibly meet she's
terrifying even though she's in her late
70s
she's a walnut farmer in Northern
California she scared the bejesus out of
me so I said Ellen tell me what was that
moment like
well she said he was real skinny he'd
lost about 80 pounds you know a leg
weighs around 30
and they shaved all the hair off his
head for the lice and all of his teeth
were gone they'd been knocked out in the
accident but he looked good to me
and that man was Ted Lawson who would go
on to write a best-seller called thirty
seconds over Tokyo which would be made
into an MGM movie starring Van Johnson
and spessart Tracy and Robert Mitchum
and it would be the only really good
movie about the Doolittle Raid there's a
number of other ones and they're quite
terrible so that's one happy ending but
unfortunately many of the other endings
are not so good well let's do one more
happy ending Jimmy Doolittle gets back
and it takes him quite a long time and
he's met by George Marshall and HAP
Arnold who tell him to get cleaned up
because they've got to pick him up and
he gets in the car and they pick him up
in there driving and Jimmy says where
are we going and Arnold and Marshall say
we're going to the White House so you
can get the Medal of Honor and Jimmy
says I don't deserve the Medal of Honor
and HAP Arnold and George Marshall his
bosses say we think you do deserve the
Medal of Honor
so they arrive at the White House and in
fact Jimmy's wife Joe had been brought
over from California so she could see
this moment and they hand her the
certificate saying about the medal of
honor and she's so nervous to be in the
White House she's crumpling the
certificate and Marshall tries thinking
whether or not he should take it back
from her but he says that won't be good
either
so Jimmy accepts his message his medal
excuse me and but he tells Roosevelt
that he's only accepting it on behalf of
the entire 80 member squadron of his
Raiders that they deserve it as much as
he does and in fact he would never feel
he deserved that medal so believe it or
not here are Raiders being carried in
sedan chairs they would be hidden under
bamboo mats in boats they would be
hidden between the robes of Elder
Chinese priests they would use every
single thing they had to carry them
across China and here is Jimmy with his
crew your United after 24 hours and here
is Jimmy with his wrecked plane
he would always claim that the Doolittle
Raid was not a success he would say well
we lost all the planes and we lost some
of the boys and here is Harry carrier
reunite
and here is FDR giving Jimmy his Medal
of Honor and that's his wife with the
hat and that's a HAP Arnold to your left
and George Marshall to your right and
after he gets his Medal of Honor before
heading the 8th Air Force which carpet
bombed Germany and make sure that
there's no lifts Wafaa to Menace d-day
Jimmy goes on a tour and here he is
visiting North American Aviation which
manufactures the far superior b25 see
now at this moment they men flew b25
bees and here is Ted Lawson on the far
right with Ellen behind him and the two
other injured crewman from his plane at
Walter Reed receiving the order of the
clouds from the Chinese Air Force and
here is the not so happy part of the
story we come to next because they
landed in occupied territory eight of
the men were capturing because they had
bombed with the Japanese considered
civilian territory they were convicted
of being war criminals they were then
manufactured confessions Hirohito the
Emperor Tojo the Prime Minister and
Sugiyama the head of the army then
looked at these manufactured confessions
and decided that three of the men's
crimes were especially heinous
and they were executed by firing squad
under treatment of the Japanese one of
the men was then starved to death and in
fact the other four would spend all of
World War two from April of 42 to the
surrender in August of 45 as prisoners
of Japan they would get absolute minimal
nutrition absolute minimal water they
would be tortured they would be kept in
solitary confinement one of them would
become more or less an alcoholic that's
this one his name is Bob hi one of them
would become insane he would eventually
be rescued by Jimmy Doolittle a year
after the war had ended naked and
unidentified in an
mental hospital when he tried telling
people that he was a Dolittle Raider it
only confirmed that he must be crazy but
one of them would find God in prison and
oh excuse me look the one way that you
can really see how the Doolittle Raid
affected America is that when Roosevelt
announced that three of them had been
executed in the next day Americans in
1943 bought 11 billion dollars worth of
war bonds it was an astounding sum it
was the largest number sold in a 24-hour
period okay
one man finds God in prison he decides
that the secret to ending human misery
is forgiveness he comes back to the
United States he goes to school to
become a minister he meets a woman who
is also a Methodist they get married
have a child and the ministry asked him
where do you want to go and he says
Japan he spends the next thirty years of
his life preaching a religion of
forgiveness in Japan
and one man he converts to this religion
is this man here the Doolittle Raid was
conceived as an answer for Pearl Harbor
this is the man who led the aerial
assault at Pearl Harbor he was converted
by Jake DeShazer the little shy guy you
saw a few pictures ago and that's one of
the happy endings of this story but
there's even a bigger happy ending and
that is that the experience of doing
this has bound these men into this giant
family they have stayed together as the
closest friends for 60 years they have
married each other's widows they have
named children after each other here
they are meeting in 1947 in Miami this
was a notorious affair for staying up
all night drunk and running around in
the pool now it's not quite so wild
everyone's in their late 80s and 90s but
last year they had their 60th
anniversary and next year April 18 2003
21 of them are still alive
two of them were POWs of the Nazis three
of them were POWs of the Japanese Jake
DeShazer is still alive at the age of 90
bob hite is still alive at the age of 87
and one man who was the only surviving
crewman of his plane chase Nielsen is
still alive at 86 hopefully all 21 will
still be alive on April 18 2003 when
they will have their 61st reunion
they'll be dedicating the Jimmy
Doolittle Air & Space Museum
it's being held and California and you
will all be invited thank you very much
I'm sorry that's a Travis Air Force Base
in California which is between
Sacramento and San Francisco are there
any questions okay well American command
had no idea about was that the Japanese
High Command was in the middle of a
terrible argument should our Navy keep
going and keep expanding by taking over
the American atoll of Midway from which
they could blockade or invade Hawaii or
should we retrenched and consolidate our
position the sea lane next Midway was
the one used by the Hornet to carry the
Doolittle Raiders so the decision was
made to attack Midway and in fact
historically this is what's so crucial
about the Doolittle Raid it triggered
the attack on Midway since we could
translate Japanese transcriptions we
knew they were coming they suffered a
terrible defeat and you could say that
really the story of the first two years
of the Pacific Theater is Pearl Harbor
Doolittle Raid Midway and Midway
reversed the course of the war and made
sure that the Japanese Navy was never an
aggressive force again yes any of the
survivors come back go back into combat
and what subsequent kill but you
mentioned some were ended up in Nazi
prison kids so I take it that they went
back and went back except the injured
ones and it was actually a big surprise
to me you think after doing something
like this they'd get to go home but what
happened is that the Army Air Corps
didn't have enough men to go around and
they needed everyone they got most of
them were reassigned to CBI China Burma
India but in fact one of the most
unbelievable stories is that one of them
and he's alive today and his name is
Davy Jones survives the Doolittle raid
is reassigned to bombing Italy is shut
down is captured by the Nazis is set to
Stalag Luft 3 there he's put to work by
RAF guys the British air force digging
tunnels using a little sled on a track
in a little candle he's known as Tokyo
Jones but at the last minute he's not
able to use that tunnel to get out
because they're capturing so many Airmen
putting them in this prison and that
tunnel digging became known as the Great
Escape
so some when one guy survives the
Doolittle Raid it gets into the Great
Escape I don't know if he's tremendously
lucky or tremendously not but anyway
unbelievable
yes how did the Raiders no word to bomb
or have their targets
well the American attache is in Tokyo
had been taking pictures for many years
of these kinds of things because Tokyo
had been running attacks in China since
1931 so they were already considered
something of a hostile force and they
were actually getting ready for all this
much more than we really know oh yeah
when the surviving Raiders brought out
of China most of them were flown to
India and then it would take them almost
two weeks to come back to the United
States because at that time the airlines
would travel in this Puddle Jumper
method of flying it took Jimmy two weeks
and he had you know urgent clearance so
he could get his medal yes it was yes
it's a Nagoya ko Bay Yokohama and I
think one more I think it was for others
there's an entire urban belt that
straddles the middle of Japan and it was
industrial and military sites in all of
them yes
they ran into the British Consulate and
they were then shipped back to the
United States yes he was 45 he died at
the age of 97 in 1994 yes
when it was it was close
because the Russians had not declared
war against Japan in fact I I may be
wrong about this but I believe they
declare war against Japan after the
Hiroshima bomb is dropped if I'm not
mistaken and they were having a terrible
time at that moment in the West when the
vehm act going through you know ins I
think the Vermont had already passed
Moscow at this point and and and so they
were terrified of having Japan attacking
them in the East which they thought
would be triggered if they gave aid to
this crew who would bomb Tokyo and and
it was known and they thought it would
get known
yes you talked about what secrecy
surrounded the raid and yet when they
the men landed in China across a
reasonably wide geographical area seemed
like all the Chinese peasants were I
wouldn't think communications with that
was that good would know to hide these
men and to transport them to one place
how to do Chinese communicate that
message so successfully well it's
actually this incredible thing that we
really don't can't understand all that
well it was almost this rural smoke
signal kind of method and and I actually
think at this time and for quite some
time there were gangs of bandits in
rural China called guerrillas and I
think they were actually the ones who
transmitted this information but the
Raiders have story after story of this
information traveling all across the
country so two of them for example get
on a handcar and they bump their way up
this railway and they end at a railway
station and the whole town is there
waiting for them cheering and the mayor
gives a speech so it's really unclear
how this incredibly primitive
countryside who still you know using
human feces to fertilize the rice
paddies had this method of communicating
across the country but but literally
within days everyone knew who they were
it's magic yes
they were taught how to say I am an
American in Chinese but it was the wrong
Chinese China has various dialects and
they were taught how to say it I think
in Mandarin but they were were the
people they landed or spoke Fujian 'yes
yes yes quite a few of the men have gone
back to China in fact one of the
official Doolittle Raiders is a Chinese
who helped them who then came to the
United States to work as an aeronautical
engineer for the Air Force he heard
about the reunion showed up and they
made him an official Raider for saving
his life and I actually got to interview
him and the men he saved and to retell
that story so you see it from the
American in the Chinese point of view
yes what happened to the aircraft
carrier that they launched boom it would
take plate it would take part in the
Battle of Midway it would then be sunk
at the Battle of Santa Cruz it would
have a replacement chip that would
rescue the Apollo 11 astronauts after
being after they landed on the moon and
it's now a museum in California yes
see I got shot mountian over China a
little later on in the war and he was
picked up by communist and they he said
they had to at that time also hide him
from the the nationalist forces because
the Nationalists didn't want some
Americans going back who had been with
the Communist some period of time to say
how well they were doing and it wasn't a
you know a bad group of fellows it was a
well-run organization did you hear any
of that or any of this yes there's
there's an incredible book by a great
historian named Barbara Tuchman called
Joseph Stilwell and the American
experience in China
that explains why Stilwell called Chiang
kai-shek peanut-head and why you
shouldn't call Stilwell vinegar Joe and
how he had the worst job of anyone in
all of World War two and how everyone in
the Dixie mission thought mal was
terrific it's a great book but anyway
yes Japanese populace of read well it
seems to be mysterious because on the
one hand people in downtown Tokyo like
in the Ginza in the main business
district seemed to have not even noticed
because they had these air raids all the
time and everyone would sort of ignore
them you know and it so it seems like a
certain group of them didn't even notice
but it seemed like another group of them
were really terrified because they
realized that their cities were made out
of wood and paper and if the Allied
forces could bomb them they could really
destroy the cities of course what
happened in 44 with LeMay and his
version of napalm yes when your book is
the subject of yet another Doolittle
movie how do you think they'll stack up
now
well the thing that kills me about this
story is that there's so many ways of
doing this story you can do it from the
point of view of the prisoners you can
do it as a small television thing you
can do it as a big feature but hopefully
it will be better than the Pearl Harbor
movie anyway just so which so mystified
me I can't even tell you you know they
left so many great parts out of that
movie such as in the second attack at
Pearl Harbor
the smoke was so covering at both Pearl
Harbor and the various airfields on Oahu
that the the plane Japanese planes gave
up and started bombing and strafing the
suburbs who had people having children
under couches and catching the pets and
I thought why is this left out of this
movie this is incredible but anyway yes
oh yes they hit all of their targets but
it was awfully minor when you add up
everything
the Japanese estimate that 50 people
died but it's unclear how many of them
died because of the bombs or because
they were shooting their anti-aircraft
guns directly into the city because the
planes were flying so low that they
aimed at them and shot directly into
other parts of the city and the the
actually MacArthur was able to unearth
documents itemizing that all of the D
Trias that they had found after the raid
but really it was the whole issue that
the Japanese had spent almost their
entire life as an independent nation
assuming they couldn't be attacked by an
alien force and this proof that they
could and it really changed their
thinking especially Yamamoto the head of
the Navy yes
no not at all he was a the Bataan Death
March begins as the Hornet is leaving
San Francisco yes
19 the average age was 24
Jake DeShazer was 30 and in fact in the
book you can see everyone's birthday how
old everyone is and and it's actually
one of the things that really annoys me
with Hollywood in world war two you know
in World War two Tom Hanks would have
been a grandpa you know he wouldn't be
leading a mission and I really wish
they'd they make a world war two movie
where everyone looks like they just got
out of high school which is actually
what happened instead of that everyone's
40 so that would be nice but anyway you
know Doolittle was considered a very
senior figure and in fact an awful lot
of people in World War two were calling
28 year olds Pop's not to mention a 45
year old I know yes you said that the
rate really unified the man and
obviously the camaraderie still exists
if it hadn't been for this raid and you
having interviewed these individual men
and their characters and so forth do you
think they would have been friends if it
hadn't been for this you know because
they only were on this they only met
each other really because of this rate
oh no they're very different they come
from all over the country Jimmy grew up
in Alaska in fact a lot of them became
joined the Army Air Corps because the
Depression had destroyed them
financially some were career they'd been
to ROTC they wanted a career in the
service from the get-go but a whole
number of them ended up in the airforce
because they were expecting to inherit a
family business it had been destroyed in
the depression whether it was a bank or
a farm or whatever so it was a very
great leveler the depression where these
men probably would have never known each
other if it hadn't been for that yes
hangers Jane ohio's you got it right
Patterson the museum there has a big to
little exhibit and they actually have
the only they took an older model b25
and reconstructed it to look like a 25 B
so they and that's where the Air Force
museum is yeah yes
gently standeth in the way yes quite a
few of those it's very thrilling I would
say well to get some juicy stories out
of that even though it all ends up well
yes or any of Jimmy Doolittle's family
still alive yes his son is still alive
and he read the manuscript and he didn't
get mad at me even though I said Jimmy
Doolittle has balls the size of your
head so I was very relieved yes
any questions unanswered that you
weren't able to you know figure oh yes
there's a whole bunch of them and it's
one of the great things of working oh
there's a really there's a whole number
of them and is a wonderful conundrum the
head of the Navy King and the head of
the Air Force Army Air Corps Army Air
Forces and I think that wasn't yeah I
think he made it to the air for Arnold
hated each other's guts and you get to
see it in their memoirs where they argue
over what Roosevelt knew about this raid
so that King claims he knows nothing
whatsoever and Arnold claims he knows
every step that happened but neither of
them make sense because Roosevelt was
too pushy to be left out of the loop
entirely and he was too chatty to be
brought in the loop fully so it's it's a
mystery that will remain forever and
their memoirs contradict each other yes
yeah plaque by the airfield that he did
the instrument landing it's outside
Danville New Jersey oh sorry there was a
little RCA factory there where he worked
on the electronics and the fields still
there they haven't let anything grow on
it yet you know that's great
he's 1927 it's really a fantastic story
and and you know he had such an
engineering mind you hear him describe
it and it sounds like nothing you know
and then you think about what he really
did I mean the most heartbreaking thing
I ever heard was right before he died
Jimmy said there's never been a time in
my life when I've been fully
satisfied with myself what do you want I
mean I was 45 when I started writing
this book and he's 45 been going into
combat and all I could think was Jimmy
what are you doing
anyone else yes when when did you how
long did it take you to write the
research and all that kind of stuff and
sometimes there's an interesting story
behind titles of books and hiya the
inspiration get is rain interesting
thing about well I spent three dog years
writing this book what happened was I
thought why is it because when we read
when they introduced you your background
it didn't seem like this was yeah it was
different than your background well what
happened was when I was an editor I
wrote some books on the side and they
were sort of small and then when I left
being an editor I thought I need to
write a big one and what's going to be
really big and I don't know if you know
the term and bodybuilding bump up but
when you add weights on to make your
muscles grow it's called bumping up and
I needed a bump up and I was looking
around for a story to do a book on and I
came across an old issue of American
history magazine and it had the story of
the Doolittle Raid in it now my
introduction wasn't quite right my
father was in the Army Air Corps in
World War two under MacArthur
my mother was a air traffic controller
in Atlanta and I have an uncle who's a
career navigator and I never heard of
the Doolittle Raid until I read this
article in this magazine so there was a
combination of being terribly drawn to
it as a human drama not even as a war
story my next books about the 18th
century but there is a I was terribly
drawn to it as this incredible story of
ordinary people who actually do change
the clock of history they actually
turned the clock of history with what
they did in deciding to do this mission
and it's terribly inspiring but also I I
felt shamed that I had never heard of
this and I really felt like any American
should know about this story and when I
started interviewing and talking to
people it turns out that almost everyone
over the age of 55 and World War 2 bosse
knows about this story as well as
everyone else knows about Kennedy and
King being assassinated but almost
everyone under 55 has never heard of it
and
the Pearl Harbor movie didn't help so
hopefully this will help a little but
what happened in the writing is that
there were five previous books written
about this so I thought the research
part of the job would be fairly easy and
the writing would be very hard and in
fact the opposite ended up happening
because I hope none of your military
historians but when you're writing under
the strictures of journalism you run
against problems when you start using
military historians who seem to have an
easy time accepting one person's version
of things and don't double-check with
another person to see if that's actually
what happened so I ended up having to
redo the research from scratch I think I
read over 80,000 documents to do this
story so the research ended up being
quite tremendous but the writing ended
up not being so difficult because one of
the things I came across was this
tremendous find I don't know if you know
this but when you write a big nonfiction
book you learn to depend on the kindness
of librarians and one of the incredible
libraries is the Air Force Historical
Association which is down in Maxwell
Alabama and their research librarians
were like the white knights I mean I'm
so in love with them I can't even tell
you
they turned up this cache of oral
interviews that the men had done 30
years ago when a lot more of them were
alive so I was able to bring back a lot
of the guys and I was able to actually
get the guys to tell the story in their
own words I was able to license excerpts
from Jimmy Doolittle's memoirs from 30
seconds over Tokyo from Jake DeShazer
who becomes the missionaries memoirs
from the memoirs of one of the guys in
Russia plus I was able to use these oral
interviews and my own interviews so that
almost everyone who takes part in this
mission gets to say something sooner or
later so because they have so many
fantastic things to say and they're so
great and and their stuff was so good
the writing wasn't so bad but the
research made you want to die yes
you made two comments earlier that that
I'm interested in your perspective as a
historian on when we started the evening
you were talking about the comparison
between 9/11 and and Pearl Harbor you
said they weren't it wasn't a real lot
of the comparison really isn't there and
then when you're talking about the
effect of the rate in Japan you were
talking about how the Japanese Feltham
themselves isolated from attack because
of the ocean and this the psychological
effect of the raid was the biggest part
and I'm wondering if that is not if you
don't draw that comparison between
instead of 9/11 Pearl Harbor 9/11 and
this rate well what happens with this
story I turn this book in the week
before 9/11 so I then had to go back and
change a few little things as the
introduction said something like perhaps
today we don't have any heroes anymore
so I had to change that but I pretty
much did nothing to try and emphasize
any connections with current events
because what happens is that with this
book it's sort of like the old cliche of
the closer you look at a grain of sand
you see the world this book this story
resonates historically in so many ways
it's really endless how you can compare
it to modern situation and not only
about how it took four years to have a
war with Japan in seven years to occupy
and the only reason we got out after
seven was because we were more worried
about China and the point you just
mentioned so one of the great things
that appeared to me while I was in the
middle of writing this book was I
suddenly thought to myself you know
everyone in the publishing industry is
wrong people who spend 27 dollars buying
a hardcover book are really smart I can
write this book thinking that the people
who are reading it are really smart and
I don't have to treat them like they're
dumb or talk down to them and do
anything so if you read it you can find
tremendous a number of analogies but I
actually don't enjoy making any of them
myself I think it's more fun for you to
find them however I do have to tell any
of you Air Force guys you can't win a
battle using only the Air Force I'm
sorry if
anyone else well thank you all so much I
can't tell you how
Craig Nelson is author of the first
heroes the extraordinary story of the
Doolittle Raid America's first world war
to victory it's published by Viking a
division of penguin Putnam visit penguin
Putnam comm for more information book TV
is brought to you every weekend on
c-span to has a public service of your
cable